je vais aller chercher le courrier en
question et je vous le rapporte le
filtre mon ami violent je vous dis
habitués du viol pas tout de suite
monsieur madame a tout de suite le
rapport depuis 1808 guignols fait rire
les petits comme les grands de père en
fils les marionnettistes font vite de
nombreuses aventures à ce drôle de
bonhomme des pièces en plusieurs actes
comme les pièces de théâtre classique
mais ici le plus important c'est la
morale de l'histoire c'est un spectacle
culturel éducatif pour les enfants
il apprend aux enfants à ne pas voler à
faire bien dans la vie car il ya le
gendarme de gendarmes et les voleurs en
prison des guignols explique aux enfants
qu'il ne faut pas voler si l'on finit en
prison contrairement au théâtre ou à la
télévision ici les enfants interagissent
directement avec les quatre personnages
ce jour là l'histoire de guignol est le
facteur remporte un grand succès auprès
des plus jeunes comme des plus âgés
crois que c'est important que les gens
sachent écouter autre chose que la
télévision fils et fille mais là ils
étaient concentrés pour aller au cinéma
d'autres activités mais c'est vrai que
les respecte et de marionnettes c'est
moi c'est moi courant ça c'est peut-être
un peu perdu en france ils ne sont plus
qu'une centaine de marionnettistes à
voyager de ville en ville pour présenter
leur spectacle
avis aux nostalgiques guignol est en
représentation tous les jours à 16
heures jusqu'au 23 avril au jardin
botanique